puede haber tomado más de un mes pero
finalmente mitch mcconnell ha reconocido
la victoria electoral de joe biden el
líder de la mayoría en el senado terminó
semanas de silencio un día después de
que el colegio electoral confirmará el
resultado sobre hoy quiero felicitar al
presidente electo joe biden el
presidente electo no es un desconocido
para el senado se ha dedicado al
servicio público durante muchos años
también quiero felicitar a la
vicepresidenta electa nuestra colega de
california la senadora harris más allá
de nuestras diferencias todos los
americanos pueden estar orgullosos de
que nuestra nación tenga una mujer
vicepresidenta por primera vez en su
camino a georgia el estado que
determinará la mayoría del senado en una
segunda vuelta el 5 de enero yo wyden
pidió derrotar a los republicanos lo que
significaría el fin de mitch mcconnell
como presidente de la cámara alta
independientemente yo vaivén dio las
gracias a su rival de larga data les
dije que aunque nosotros estemos en
desacuerdo en muchos temas hay cosas en
las que podemos trabajar juntos siempre
hemos sido sinceros el uno con el otro y
acordamos que nos reuniríamos más pronto
que tarde y esto
deseando trabajar con él sin embargo
todavía no hay señales de concesión del
propio donald trump que siga haciendo
acusaciones infundadas de fraude
electoral generalizado no ha recibido la
reacción del presidente todavía pero
está persiguiendo un litigio en curso le
referiré a la campaña para más adelante
perder después de donald trump mcconnell
es el republicano de más alto cargo así
que se espera que más miembros del
congreso de su partido rompan filas con
el presidente permitiendo un proceso de
transición más suave